les affaires se traitent par la prudence
par l'autorité et les bons avis tu
aurais dû relire cicéron avant de te
lancer dans des opérations financières
dont tu n'as pas mesuré les conséquences
désastreuses un bon patron de pme c'est
un patron capable d'engager tout son
avoir financier dans son entreprise
c'est celui qui exerce des fonctions
réelles et unique de responsabilité et
de gestion celui qui met en jeu son
savoir et en cas d'échec son honneur je
ne suis pas certain que tu puisses le
vanter de réunir toutes ces qualités là
à tamaris à vin capable d' hannah et il
s'est tu compte en sortir comment déjà
vous demandant d'arrêter d'insulter dur
ma femme et l'office ta femme est avant
tout ma fille et mon fils mon petit fils
l'idée de les imaginer un jour dans une
situation précaire
par ta faute motorisée de parler comme
je longtemps que cela te plaise ou non